erwachsene trauen sich offenbar nicht
mehr selber wahlkampf zu machen und
selber für ihre position auf die straße
zu gehen oder zu werben deswegen
instrumentalisieren sie die die
eigentlich noch gar nicht wählen dürfen
und mit politik vielleicht noch gar
nichts zu tun haben nämlich ihre kinder
so geschehen jetzt mit einem 9 man kann
fast sagen erpresserschreiben in dem
enkel ihre großeltern auffordern sollen
für eine bessere klima sichere zukunft
zu wählen wen sie da wählen sollen das
wird von prominenten gefordert ist
natürlich offenkundig die grünen es
handelt sich also sozusagen um eine
grüne version des enkeltricks und
gestern abend habe ich bei prosieben
eine sendung gesehen in der kinder armin
laschet interviewt haben und diese
kinder stellten auf einmal fragen weil
sie wie ich übrigens auch einen knopf im
ohr hatten die sie selber offenkundig
gar nicht verstanden haben so sollten
sie armin laschet fragen ob er hans
georg maßen für einen nach sicherheit
sie sagten aber nah sie ist hans-georg
maßen ein narr sie weil sie das wort
noch gar nicht kannten diese kinder die
um die zehn jahre alt war hat man auch
dinge im spiegel gelesen und setzten
immer wieder sehr sehr sehr hartnäckig
nach was daran lag dass jemand in der
regie saß und den kindern gesagt hat so
jetzt stellt ihr nochmal die frage
erkennbar war die kinder wussten gar
nicht worüber sie reden mein appell wenn
erwachsene politische ansichten haben
sollten sie doch gerade in wahlzeiten
den schneid haben die selber zu äußern
und dafür nicht kinder zu
instrumentalisieren
was du da gestern im fernsehen erlebt
hast ist glaube ich eine neue form von
fernsehen und eine neue form von polit
kandidaten die neue form des fernsehens
besteht darin dass redakteure und
autoren eine idee haben und sagen kinder
wir lassen kinder politiker fragen und
dass dann die berater ihren politiker
sein da musst du hin gehen kinder ist
gut 1 scholz und ein laschet können in
der direkten auseinandersetzung mit
kindern nicht gut aussehen und kinder
sind und ich habe das oft erlebt man
glaubte an diese spontanität an diese
unbedarftheit der kinder die das alles
entspannt machen nicht in diesem bereich
nicht dem politischen bereich wenn es um
tiere geht wenn es um ihre welt geht
dann ja aber jemand mit einem knopf im
ohr
in ein studio auf kandidaten der
politischen szene loszuschicken das ist
perfide und das kann nur daneben gehen
und der profi in mir der ans fernsehen
glaubt ihr das glauben will was da
passiert der ärgert sich und dem man
sich die fußnägel hoch warum muss man
kinder instrumentalisieren waren muss
man ihnen fragen auf ob true ihren die
ihnen so nicht gekommen wären und warum
muss man politiker ins messer laufen
lassen die ihre zeit damit verplempert
die kinder übrigens dann auch gefragt ob
armin laschet tatsächlich dagegen ist
dass männer heiraten dürfen worauf wir
dann sagt er das natürlich totaler
quatsch und dann haben die kinder gesagt
das haben wir aber im spiegel gelesen
vor vier jahren da waren sie ungefähr 1
5 oder das ist auch eine frage der
zehnjährigen auf den nägeln brennt in
voller transparenz wir haben auch mal
kinder markus söder befragen lassen aber
die durften ihre fragen schicken die sie
zur corona pandemie hatten die ihre
schule betroffen haben und sie haben
fragen gefragt die sie tatsächlich ihren
alltag betroffen haben aber die hat man
keinen knopf im ohr und die haben auch
nicht fragen gestellt die sie selber gar
nicht verstehen ich frag mich warum gibt
es in diesem wahlkampf dieses bedürfnis
die eigene politische ansicht die eigene
agenda über dieses vehikel kinder zu
transportieren wir erleben dass von
anfang an das schildern oft sind es
grüne dass sie im zug gehört haben dass
dem kind gesagt habe ich habe solche
angst dass das wasser steuer sind
ergebnisse von marketing tools wo man
einfach sagt es ist einfach für die
aufmerksamkeit gut wenn wir es so fahren
wenn wir es so präsentieren das hat
nichts mit mit einer kindlichen mit
einem neuen interesse von kindern zu tun
natürlich wissen wir dass die zukunft
jetzt ein großes wahlkampfthema ist und
dass ein zehnjähriger mehr zukunft vor
sich hat als einer in unserer in meinem
alter sehr
interessant für mich ist das einfach
quasi dass das sinnbild der totalen
infantilisierung der politik und der
heutigen welt also ich meine wie sie in
der sitzung seit jahren vor ein paar
jahren sind ja alle diese kinder
heiligen daraus späten hinterhergerannt
diese geräte an einem kind
minderjährigen mädchen mit einer
wahrnehmungsstörung die haben da quasi
zu einer neuen heiligen erklärt alle
politiker world economic forum weil
diese hoch dekorierten schaumschläger
die darum laufen sind der in trier
marschiert und jetzt sind wir so in
einer zeit wo man die kinder auf eine
ganz merkwürdige art zu den leitfiguren
zu den zu den maßgeblichen frage stellen
erklären das ist eigentlich eine eine
fürchterliche missbrauch diese kinder
denn eigentlich haben ja die erwachsenen
ich bin viel worte wir haben auch eine
verantwortung diese kinder zu führen
aber wenn sich ein politiker hinstellt
und so tut als würde er jetzt quasi von
diesen kindern geführt und angeleitet
werden ist dass der gipfel der
unseriosität das ist ein mangel von
ernsthaftigkeit im wahlkampf das ist
auch verzweiflung die haben
offensichtlich keine themen und es ist
eine realitätsflucht in eine ganz
primitive inszenierung wo am schluss wie
du gesagt hast auf den missbrauch von
kindern für politische zwecke hinaus
läuft am schlimmsten noch von den grünen
dass dieser ihre großeltern unter druck
setzen sollen also man richtet sich
eigentlich an zwei etwas fragile
menschengruppen an die älteren die
vielleicht schon etwas nicht mehr so
ganz kognitiv dabei konnten die kleinen
die man manipulieren kann ich finde das
schlimm das ist ein fonds wie die bild
-zeitung das müsst ihr jetzt wochenlang
müsste das kanalisieren ich glaube diese
sehnsucht roja das ja abgeleitet warum
politiker da sozusagen sich in dieser
umgebung ich glaube dürfen einen
wichtigen aspekt nie vergessen ist das
schlechte gewissen ich glaube dass die
jetzt amtierende politiker generation
viele übrigens kinderlos in der
bundesregierung mitbekommen haben aus
den letzten wochen und monaten dass sie
die kinder verlassen haben dass sie gar
keine politik gemacht habe für die
kinder das sind die kinder in den
schulen allein gelassen haben mit der
pandemie und mit masken im schulzimmer 2
und all das wird überkompensiert ich
habe auch den eindruck dass alle jetzt
ich habe schon angst wenn ich schon so
laschet oder werbung sie dass sie sich
ein kind greifen damit den fotos
sozusagen entsteht ich habe als ich
morgens morgen ins studio kommen und das
ist aber meine elfjährige aus
ich glaube dass das da steckt was ganz
tief unterbewusstes drin wir haben die
kinder vergessen und jetzt müssen wir
besonders viel mit ihnen reden was
natürlich absurd ich gehe mal so weit
ich finde ein kanzlerkandidat oder eine
kanzlerkandidatin muss überhaupt nicht
direkt mit kindern reden sondern sie
sollen eine gute politik für kinder
machen weil sie verstehen um was es geht
und weil sie sich um die zukunft
gedanken machen aber dazu braucht man
sich eigentlich nicht von dem kind
fragen lassen und maßen nazis wenn
kinder kinder fragen stellen würden dann
kommen wir ins geschäft und jetzt komme
ich zu meinem entscheidung mir ist
rätselhaft wie die entourage von armin
laschet ihn in eine solche situation
bringen kann dass die autoren schreiben
die macher die manager des wahlkampfs
ich sagen herr laschet oder armin oder
wie auch immer ich glaube das machen wir
nicht denn da werden kinder mit knopf im
ohr sitzen die irgendwelche erwachsenen
fragen stellen das muss man natürlich
vorher raus finden dass man es als
sender versucht wirklich fehlerhaft man
muss nur wissen man muss davon passieren
ich meine kenntnis ist sozusagen wenn
man über den tisch gezogen wird können
ja immer zweiter zone einer der zieht
und einer der sich ziehen lässt der
einzige knopf im ohr bei kindern sollten
eigentlich die steiff tiere seien
nein aber ich habe ja die ganze aktion
jetzt neben der sendung die ausgestrahlt
wurde schon über social media verfolgen
können und fand das wirklich auch
abstrus was da läuft vor allem auch wenn
man kinder grundsätzlich
instrumentalisiert für eine politik aber
dann auch noch für eine grüne politik wo
dahinter steckt ja schuldenmacherei das
heißt eigentlich genau diese generation
meine generation die nachfolgenden
generation werde ja durch diese grüne
politik und was auch im wahlprogramm
steht enorme schulden anhäufen gehen was
genau diese generation zurückzahlen muss
in zukunft und daher finde ich das legen
das ganze schon perfide und man sollte
ganz klar kinder nicht
instrumentalisieren für einen wahlkampf
es gibt auch ich habe mir überlegt was
was hier so gesagt habe und dass mir ein
gedanke gekommen
nein eigentlich werden die kinder in der
politik eingesetzt in den schlimmsten
regime es gibt zum beispiel nordkorea
oder stellen sie sowieso kinder roboter
auf die dann so lange mit seinem realen
lachen müssen sie so fein und schwingen
wenn ihr gewicht oder auf einem
kunststoff
und in anderen regimen ich meine ein
stalin hatte auch als ein bisschen
politisch probleme hatte hat dass ich
mit kindern berichten lassen und die
getätschelt eigentlich ist das eine
wirklich eine
fürchterliche politische regime erinnern
der strategie die man eigentlich nicht
zu lang sagt amerikanischen wahlkampf
dazu spricht wenn man nach dem essen
wieder um genau wie es küssen und das
ist jetzt ein bisschen genau dass ich
glaube da muss ich sagen diese tromp die
römer verunglimpft wurde ich meinen
traumpartner immerhin das nicht gemacht
hat soll man diese diesen fehler diese
dinger dann nicht gemacht aber dass man
jetzt in deutschland in diese richtung
geht das zeigt einen grad der
verzweiflung
dieser wahlkampf führenden parteien der
euch beunruhigen muss aus deutscher und
schweizer auch wenn man's deutschland
schlecht geht an kommunale deutschen in
die schweiz versucht man habe
deutschland nicht so gut ist versucht
man dadurch eigentlich sympathischer zu
wirken wenn man sich von kindern
interviews oder was was denkt man sich
dann dabei wenn wenn diese pläne
geschmiedet werden das ist ja genau der
danken gedanken fehler was du
angesprochen was klaus dass die berater
sagen muss ein pass mal auf da kannst du
nur im wahrsten sinne des wortes ganz
ganz alt aussehen die werden dich keine
wenn sie dich entweder fragen was kostet
was kostet ein liter milch dann siehst
du alt aus und wenn sie dich das fragen
was man ihnen im knopf zu murmelt dann
siehst du erst recht alt aus da konnte
nichts draus werden aber die redakteure
die auf diese idee kam super machen was
wir hören und dann könnte ja noch nein
sagen wir haben genau gewusst wenn ein
laschet oder einen scholz einem oder
eine frau bei einem gespräch mit kindern
aus dem weg geht dann hat man sie
irgendwo am wickel das ist auch beste
kinderfrage gestern übrigens die gab es
dann doch noch an ein mit laschen wie
wär dein name als drache als ein jahr
[Musik]